what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here today I am gonna
do a first time watching for a movie I
have heard unanimous praise about keeps
popping up in my timeline as a
must-watch film all I know about it are
a couple of basic things which is that
it takes place in World War one it's a
foreign language I believe that language
is in German South Korean it's a World
War one I think it's I think it's a
German film or at least it's intro I
don't know but I haven't seen a trailer
for it and that is the movie All Quiet
on the Western Front I'm excited for it
it's got some Oscar nominations best
picture I believe being one of them some
other categories I'm assuming too thank
you for being here please go ahead leave
a like that'd be very much appreciated
also be sure to subscribe click the
notification Bell to get notified when
we got a video up on this channel that
must pique your interest as always
full-length Reaction watch the longest
resync up with your own copy of All
Quiet on the Western Front available for
our super sexy Rejects at our patreon
page uh at our patreon we actually
launched a website recently to make it
much easier to navigate all of our posts
thank you to everyone to show your
support thus far alrighty guys let's see
what the hype is all about
foreign
[Music]
oh man
[Applause]
what the [__]
Jesus the
choreography on these shots
this is
horrifying
God damn
that is an opener
foreign
for a ride aren't we I don't know much
about World War One much less the German
side too
[Music]
and that like boom synths score
The Dread of this movie Just oozes off
the Screen Man
damn the earnest hopefulness on these
dudes
it's like they're so
I don't know if the right words
disillusioned but they are just not
mentally prepared whatsoever huh
you guys want to be able to clients okay
uh
uh yikes
okay it looks like Tom Felton I'm
absolutely
50s
oh I'm about to get a strong dose of
reality boys
well it's a caring guy
oh
yeah
that's encouraging
everything here is so visually striking
you can feel it's like the entire
environment it's like you touch it that
it sounds stupid to say it just really
feels like you're here
cartoon
just love how in the background they're
just keeping all the action alive
everything's just really moving
yeah you're gonna be like the first to
go aren't you
oh wow even that rack Focus shot is
great
such a blurred background and then the
second you do like wow there's so much
environment
oh
dude
man they're really good at making you
feel like this this main character has a
really good shot at dying
strange sense of
like a haunting wonder and it's
aura
a lot of work I feel like you're gonna
be the first one to go man
[Music]
um
get out of here you're insane
oh my God
oh damn
baby
huh
you're a lucky ass Survivor dude
man just like how they keep that smoke
going is that practical
it's such a fascinating experience to me
because as
realistically Bleak as they're capturing
it like
film side is going look at this
technical Marvel we're watching right
now
just feels like they're waiting around
here to die
it's like the very next day you become
privy to so Much Death
oh those is glasses
foreign
he was the first one to go
it's like he's looking at him
man that sucks
he was just begging to go home
I got the physical
achiness of all this just really feels
like they're down and dirty in the mud
these actors
oh [__] is that Daniel bro
you think it is
when did World War One ending
chocolate
ah
Emma now this guy moves like a man with
experience
if there's one thing very tangible about
this movie it is the exhaustion
oh God
oh
[Music]
I don't like seeing animals die
ah we didn't have to see it
yeah this sounds like a memory you'd
hold on to
three women
whoa
oh he's just going for it
yes
[Laughter]
and
he's just leaving
to practice
dumpling perfect timing for that
oh [__]
oh damn so Christopher
damn who was this guy before the war
mingham
office
that's a really poignant line
all people are going to want to know is
about when if they had close combat that
is usually what people inquire about huh
but captioning these other aspects with
the harsh lifestyle is very interesting
to me
yes then who he's got to Haute fires
that's real that's really white hey
he said oh my
God
[Music]
feels like for our soldiers at least the
time that we spend with them
that it does it's not even about the
objective of trying to win the war it's
just about surviving
holy hell
he forgot
[Music]
it worked
damn this is a very vulnerable moment
[Applause]
the most normal looking shot of the
whole movie
oh no
yeah ah
SOS
[Applause]
uh
so interesting to look back at the
beginning of this movie when
they were so enthusiastic about this
it's like since the first day they've
just wanted to go back home yeah
sounds fair
foreign
Jesus Christ the brutality man first one
man
[Music]
this could of a job as this movie does
on
gripping you with with a lot of its
violent imagery it's kind of hoping we
get the ceasefire I don't know what the
progression of the events man
it's like the blood is becoming the air
foreign
[Music]
God damn whoa
oh
enjoy some food
she's so [__] famished
oh [__]
oh no no guys guys move
girls
what a nightmare
the hell are you supposed to compete
with that [__]
oh my God there's so many of them
I really hope he doesn't die I feel like
everyone's gonna die right now
holy [__]
oh
standing all [__] high and mighty
oh my gosh it's towering over them
laughs
I was
terrifying
any character stands around dazed I I'm
just like worried they're gonna get shot
right away
nicely done
Christ
how'd they how they make this movie
oh no
oh
come on
just put him out
man this is felt entirely hopeless since
the beginning of the film yeah
that's a fact
gosh it's a racist sign these goddamn
documents
so relentless
[Music]
whoa
God this is so real
thank you
I'll just put them out man
oh
dude
you have a knife just put them out
it's good
oh
God oh God
oh God
come on come on comrade
of course
foreign
what are you doing to yourself
just human beings in this war man just
humans
gotta like close off any bit of
empathy
what happens with that empathy that wall
breaks down
what's going on with this
negotiation papers Philadelphia
Hidden book
s
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God
is your truth
is
got the little things you hold on to
just to just to have some hope of going
home
Cincinnati
[Music]
hey
thank you
help him eat
ER
[Music]
oh my God
oh that's [__] horrible man
[Music]
damn
Alex foreign
[Music]
eleven eleven eleven
haunted the next thing
they are going back
it was done
oh damn we could actually see it happen
now this has me worried please for the
love of God
the war is over
please for the love of God don't do this
oh my God
foreign
[Music]
oh no don't do this
God damn it
it goes
god what the [__]
please let him be alive
huh
yes I've told oh my God
this is such such [__] man
oh God
what a crock of [__] man that's a real
that's a real pain in the ass man
all right what
Creek
make iron MC
they've got dammit on sign words
oh this is such [__]
oh that is evil
devolved into a complete shell of the
former self huh
[Music]
completely Hollow
so unnecessary
soldiering on huh
oh
no oh
whoa
huh
man
foreign
oh that is so messed up
[Music]
that is so bad
oh my jeez us come on
[Music]
is he gonna collect paws
damn after all that
[Music]
God
as a brutal film right there
that was that was brutal
[__]
but necessary that was uh that was an
experience right there that was a really
interesting experience
what is the movie nominated for it has
to be nominated for
best city photography right
All Quiet on the Western Front
nominations
what's going on here
horror Contender for sure best pictures
that I'm gonna talk for yeah of course
I mean yeah I know it's
I like on a technical side it is
masterfully done it is so masterfully
executed
um
yeah that was that was a I mean like the
experience in the technical filmmaking
side is is great you know like they're
it's interesting like I think 1917 was
it was a fantastic film as well
and another technical Marvel with its
cinematography and such uh this was a
lot more Rough Around the Edges because
it never has this
it never has this angle of showing
anyone like a hero like if anything you
see people as as victims of of this war
and uh the the dangers of of nationalism
really is a big part of a lot of these
key moments
you know like the the hypocrisy and of
these people in power
and and how these soldiers are just
human beings who are just used uh it's
disgusting it's really disgusting and
and in this film I I think also really
captures the
can't really find a better word but uh
the pointlessness of War
as well especially in these
circumstances
you know the uh frivolousness of it all
so it's it has this like a ironic
death like is this based on a true story
I gotta I gotta look this up it is all
quiet
on the Western Front a true story
not directly based on a true story
oh it's based on a book
oh and then there's the there's a much
older film I didn't know any of this oh
how interesting to know
okay
well either way I mean I could look all
that up later
um but yeah I mean showing showing like
a a like a war movie that does show you
the
the harshness of it all because
sometimes there is a bit of a strange
conflict that one that might I myself
can have with this sort of thing like
you know I covered Schindler's List on
this channel and that had not a shred of
wow this is just it that just felt like
a documentary to me it felt so real and
and that was such a a wonderfully
crafted film this is not like that
because this is crafted in a way where
yes so many of the shots and and the way
they've executed the production design
where I could everything looked real to
me while while of course there is visual
there's like maybe one moment that
looked like visual effects enhancement
for the most part everything looked
entirely real to me and had this amazing
haunting score that kept coming in and
out and
there was such an authenticity to
capturing these these moments of these
soldiers and and the quiet times
and the the hopelessness and and like
really a movie that does make you ask
like what is the point of this why what
is the point of this what what is the
point of of everyone risking their lives
and sacrifice themselves and then having
this almost ironic death to what happens
with Paul in in the end of
it's like right almost at the 11th like
at the left so close so close
and then dies uh it's
it's heartbreaking
and
it seems like
I'm not even sure what the point of it
is but it feels fated to be that way
but yeah I mean the the way the score
and and the way the movie itself is
executed is
it's what I meant by an interesting sort
of conflict that I could sometimes have
that I I wore I sort of process and work
through because eventually the movie
became so immersive that I stopped
looking at like having this like
filmmaker love gays over it and admiring
uh any part of it that had this sort of
Sheen quality to it because in the
beginning it is like wow look how
technically and beautifully impressive
this is and you know it is horrific to
look at but it's also pretty cool to
look at too and I can't help an Admire
and in 1917 kind of has a similar thing
for me in the beginning as well
so I can have sort of bit at odds when
the right thing to say I don't really
want to say this looks really cool but
it does look really cool because that
sounds like you know I'm being
insensitive or something but at times it
can feel like they're going for they
want it to be they want it to be
visually striking and be impressive and
beautiful and it's a film so it's okay
to to want to be that uh but at the same
time I I guess the the worrisome part of
falling into that
headspace with thinking that with a war
film is it could feel like you're
glorifying the violence more but I felt
like this movie Never
got came close to that for me never came
close to that even in the beginning when
it I was like wow this looks great this
looks really cool this is a beautiful
film to look at uh it never once had any
type of sensationalism or
especially because of the fact that the
the movie itself does not have any of
this type of heroic quality to it like
it was it was literally just about
endurance and going through the motions
of what they're sort of forced to go
into and being you know like starting
off this movie
with I mean other than that like that
glorious beautiful looking battle
sequence uh really disturbing but you
know both so beautiful at the same time
the seeing Paul and his friends where
they are succumbing to what the their
country is saying like yeah you'll be
looked at as as a hero and this is great
they're excited you know but the second
they they really answer the trenches
they they're like the the morphing of
them begins instantaneously as it would
and it never is about winning it
literally is just about watch how these
people morph and
what their and how they're just used
like like the like especially with the
finale you know I'm never I haven't seen
it I didn't know there was an original
film or a book until a couple minutes
ago with a camera phone and I mean
um but seeing you know when I was
talking earlier about
um uh like the hypocrisy
um and and the abuse of in power uh in
regards to like the dangers the
nationalism
at the
at the very at the end there where he
just you like man just let them live
that it's gonna be over and then I'm
assuming in general just sends them off
like their lives are meaningless anymore
disobeys they get killed it was so
[__] up
I
was most affected by that you know and
even when you got like the one guy who
uh with the fork
at the very end of the movie on the
lives himself
you know he's
like you don't want to go home or
[__] you're already so messed up
psychologically from everything that's
that's happened
life will not be normal for you and you
you know it's like this movie does a lot
of things that a lot of war movies
pretty much do you know really capturing
the horrors of war and watching the
psychological deterioration of it it's
the kind of movie that I feel like
people could easily walk out of feeling
like it feels light on character but
it's the
so much of the character development is
in the unspoken side of watching how
they morph and react to violence as it
progresses you know like in the
beginning you see how horrified like a
character like Paul is and then with the
last 15 minutes before the war is going
to be declared over
he has become such a
such a good soldier
such a product of it all that he charges
head-on ghost kill does everything up
until the last minute
when you know
there are ways you can maybe run out the
clock but he doesn't
that's there's some disturbing ad like
that
every I really started to understand
like the powerful effects of this movie
especially within the last the last like
30 minutes of it because I didn't notice
the time when they're like the war was
over they signed it and I was like oh oh
okay this movie's gonna be over soon and
I did notice I have a little counter
here I'm like wait a minute I thought
this movie was two hours and 20 minutes
it says like it's only been an hour and
40 minutes so what are we gonna go oh my
gosh my mind started going like what's
the the rest of the movie and then you
watch as the rest of the movie unfolds
and and I actually thought that was the
most affecting stuff was everything
after the war ended because then you
really see the uh evil puppetry that is
that that goes on and the
how it doesn't feel Victoria after all
is said and done even I'm forgetting his
name but the the guy the guy who was
shot by the kid
um
like when after all is said and done not
none all of it is just feels like a
relief and not any bit of it feels
Victorious everything that they were
sold on with going into war
and then even when they are under the
belief like okay we finally gotta go
home they're not met with any of those
feelings and I like how the word is
authentic like I love how authentic
everything felt with capturing their
emotions and their reactions their
responses even seeing the guy talking
about like you hear that it's quiet like
quiet resembling this sense of peace
something that they really long for and
whereas I feel like a lot of movies
would would really like try to hammer at
home with its like slow motion or some
[__] and uh they'd really drive home the
drama and
and a sense of patriotism you know and
this doesn't do that this
really is as beautiful of a film as it
is in terms of its cinematography with
every shot being
so evoking such strong moods throughout
and feeling incredibly haunting
the way they capture the the
performances
at the same time feels like we're just
poking in at their a real natural human
moments in time
and it's a really sad movie it's a
really gripping movie it's a very it's
very well executed and I I love the pace
of it all
you know it's like oh there's a lot of
familiar things that it explores that
I've seen a lot of war movies do so far
but I would not
I still wouldn't be like it negates a
lot of the experience though for me like
I thought that this was this was really
great and I've never I've never seen a
movie from the other side any more movie
I've seen has really just been about the
Americans so I haven't seen something
that focuses on on this specific section
uh
yeah this was this was about I thought
this was powerful and and very
impressively made with a great cast and
a wonderful wonderful set design they
made everything feel very real
I feel like there's something I wanted
to point out that I that has not come
into mind at the moment at this moment
in time but hey I thought they did an
excellent job and
I like everything everywhere all at once
is my favorite movie of the year but I'm
hoping with the I don't know if this
video will get out before the Oscars but
I'm hoping with the Oscars that this
wins best cinematography because I I
think out of every movie I've seen this
for I'm thinking out of every move for
2022 that I that I've at least I haven't
seen on them all that are nominated I
feel like this is the best best looking
one because from beginning to end every
every visual moment like you're dealing
with so many different times of day as
well
it's so hard to make every one of those
pop and they really do you just watch as
this you just like it it absorbs the
atmosphere so well I don't know who this
director is but I thought I did an
excellent job too like this film is
edited really well like while it can
capture the scuzziness and the human
turmoil very well like my favorite scene
is when Paul and that French soldier uh
he's stuck in the terrain with them and
he
you know he
like you're not taught to view the enemy
as human but then in that moment he just
sees in his dying moments that he is
just a human being
it's for me it's like and then at the
end of it whole like just took a few
meters with this text at the end you're
like damn talk about how futile uh so
much of this is
anyway uh I thought this was a that was
a great film I did I thought this was a
great film with some very great
performances and it was very striking
throughout and uh
glad I gotta watch it
hmm
all right guys well thank you for being
here and uh
yeah it just leaves an effect on you man
Jesus it just really leaves an effect on
you and I think about that last like 20
minutes that
but it was such a weird experience
because when it was wrapping up when the
war we're not wrapping up when I felt
when I thought it was wrapping up you
know I was like all right you know what
go back home and see how they're
traumatized they are psychotypical route
but damn it did not go there and and and
uh
that just
like you see the hollowness of it all
and I'm just left feeling Hollow by the
end like I wasn't even on the verge of
tears when it came to Paul I was just
I think that's why I'm
I think that's the mood it's left me
with it's it's left me Hollow but I
don't I sometimes I say that like it's a
negative thing like I have no emotion
with it but that's not it is it does
such a great job at capturing the
hollowness of the choices that are made
to put these people through these these
things that I'm left feeling Hollow by
the end of it all
uh yeah
hmm
well guys what do you think about this
movie leave your thoughts down below did
you see the original did you read the
book leave your thoughts down below
um
I'll talk to you all soon thank you for
being here
[Music]